We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here's just a good question about so-called
Obama gate.
Take away David.
I know the idea of Obama gate is ridiculous,
but we're being put to the test of specifics.
I don't have a whole lot of answers other
than it takes more than just a president asking
the FBI to investigate a candidate for something
to happen.
You need judges to approve warrants and stuff
like that.
Can you help me with life?
Listen.
Everything you're saying is absolutely right.
But the problem is you're allowing them to
put you on the defensive.
They are asserting Barack Obama committed
crimes.
Get a list of the crimes and the supporting
evidence and let's actually figure it out.
Don't feel as though you now have to argue
against.
This is like, you know, hey, listen.
There are invisible purple elephants in the
room with me right now, but they don't disturb
the air.
They make no noise.
What?
Why?
Why do if I assert that?
Why is it you now that has to disprove it?
I need to bring something to the table.
We could say extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
Apply whatever metaphor, a proverb or whatever
you want to it.
Don't allow them to put you on the defensive.
Let's start with what are the crimes that
Barack Obama committed?
Who else committed the crimes?
Let's look at that.
The U.S. code of law and we'll go from there.
Don't fall for it.
Otherwise, we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today.
We talked months ago about producer Pats pandemic
displacement part one, and it was crazy.
Today, we will bring you the incredible story.
I didn't even believe it when Pat emailed
me about it of producer Pats Pandemic Displacement
Part 2.
You will not believe what we are going to
tell you on today's bonus show.
And also, I have some prepping updates that
some of I know some of you are going to laugh
at me about, but I'm going to come clean.
I'm going to admit the truth.
On today's bonus show, get instant access
by becoming a member at Join Packman dot com
or a patron at Patry on dot com slash David
Pakman.